Today, we're going
to talk a little bit
more about billing
and coding for OMT.
So through this session,
we're going to talk
about different terminology
that will help you
better understand billing
and coding for OMT.
We're going to determine
what is important in terms
of documentation for you
and when you document
an office visit, and
especially what we need to put
in there in terms of proper
documentation of OMT.
We're going to explain
how we bill for OMT,
and then we're also
going to provide all
the different components
necessary when we're
billing for OMT and
procedures in general,
and how we document
somatic dysfunctions, the
different regions we treat,
the different techniques we
use, and how the patient
responded to treatment.
So a little bit of
background information.
it's really important to
understand that billing
and coding is a component
of the healthcare
cycle that helps
ensure that payers and
patients get reimbursed
for what's provided.
So when we have medical
billing and coding,
it translates that
patient encounter to a
language that the
healthcare facilities could
use for claim submission
and reimbursement.
when we code our visit
we're taking what occurred
during the office visit
and turning it into
something um kind of like
a receipt right so when you
go to the grocery store
these are all the different
prices when we're
providing a service as a
physician we need to code
for what we do by using these
codes a bill is generated
to give to the insurance
agencies for patients
to then get reimbursed.
By understanding these
fundamentals, you can
ensure that you get
proper reimbursement.
Errors in coding and billing
could have real severe
repercussions. So it's
important that we have a good
understanding of it and
accurately bill for what we do.
So the doctor patient
encounters starts with
the office visit.
what happens in the
office visit is between
you and the patient.
The actual billing of
it is the deciphering of
what happened, right?
So it's really important
that ultimately what
happens in that room
is documented accurately
in the progress note.
And based on what happened,
we will bill different
levels of office visit,
right? The more complex and
the more time we take, the
higher the charge, right?
If we do any additional
procedures that's not included
within the office visit,
right? So the office
visit is the evaluation and
management of the patient.
If we perform any additional
procedures, whether
it be a surgical
procedure or OMT, then
that's another separate
billable activity. So all
those things need to
be clearly documented.
The golden rule in
healthcare billing
and coding is you
don't code for it if
it's not documented
in a medical record.
If there is any question
about what happened during
that patient encounter,
ultimately it's that progress
note, that documentation
that will be referred to. And
so you as the physician are
responsible for everything
that goes into that SOAP
note or that progress note.
Just some key terminology
that we need to be aware
of when discussing medical
billing coding, right?
So when we evaluate and
then manage the patient,
we need to then list a
set of assessments. Those
assessments are medical
diagnoses, and the ICD or
International Classification
of Diseases, ICD
currently on the 10th version,
is a list of all these
different codes and diagnoses,
including osteopathic
diagnoses for services
that are provided. it.
This list of ICD, these
lists of diagnoses
are updated and revised.
They're currently
working on, of course,
the 11th revision.
And as physicians, when
we make our diagnoses,
we need to select the
code that goes with the
assessment for that patient
and add that to the note.
When the bill is sent
out, we then list those
ICD-10s and link it with
the office visit codes.
CPT, or current procedural
terminology, is a list of
procedures that are utilized
that using these codes,
it identifies different
procedures that are done.
And so if we do a skin
biopsy, if we do OMT, if
we do surgery, any sort
of procedure that's done
is listed and that is
also linked to the bill.
And so when performing
a procedure,
we look for that CPT code.
E&M evaluation and management
codes are a list of
CPT codes. So it does
fall under CPT, But E&M
evaluation and management
codes are the office visit
codes or the patient visit
codes, right? So this
is the code I select to
signify what level of
office visit during the
patient encounter occurred.
And E&M codes
also depend on the
location that you
saw the patient.
So the amount that is billed
for the CPTs or E&Ms are
set. And so when you see
somebody in the hospital
versus if you see somebody in
the office, in the outpatient
scenario, the prices might
be different with what
is set for those charges
in terms of reimbursement.
So these three terminologies
will be utilized during
the lecture to better
explain billing and coding.
So again,
anything that happens in the
office depends on anything
that happens in the
office between you and the
physician, between you and
your patient is documented
usually typically on your
SOAP note, right? So SOAP
standing for subjective, O
for objective, assessment,
A, P for plan, right? So
this framework is where
we document our patient
visit and needs to have all
these different aspects
to help clearly document
what was done, what was
discussed under subjective,
what was done, observed,
vitals, physical exam,
structural exam, going over
labs, What was your assessment?
It could include things
that you're ruling out.
And what is your
plan for the patient?
So in the subjective region,
it's really important
to have the OPQRSTA,
right? All the different
details of what the patient
presentation was about.
It's as important to also
gather any key history,
surgical history, family
history, social history,
review of systems.
All these go under subjective.
Under physical exam,
especially with OMT,
this is where we place
our findings, right?
So in the physical
exam section, you're
going to have your vital
signs. You're going
to have your key
physical exam findings,
H, E, and T exam,
heart, lungs, abdomen,
things that are pertinent
that you examine for
your patient, a good
neuromusculoskeletal exam of
patients presenting with
structural pain, right?
And then you're going
to also insert your
osteopathic somatic
dysfunction findings.
Ideally, you want to
list it by region.
So if I find somatic
dysfunctions in
the head, a cranial
dysfunction or neck,
thoracic region, if
you list it by region,
it helps with ultimately
the billing portion.
So here's a sample osteopathic
structural examination
section within your
physical exam section.
Here you can see we listed
out somatic dysfunctions
separately for four
different regions,
the head, cervical, rib,
and thoracic region.
The AOA was pushing to
have a key where you're
placing down the severity
of the dysfunction.
So here you can see out
of all these dysfunctions,
the head or OA region
was the most severe using
our key with three being
the most severe semantics
function and one being the
most mild. And then after
the treatment, within
this sample documentation,
we listed the actual
treatment and the response.
which we'll go into in
terms of how best to
go about it. But this
was a sample provided
as a template for a
proposal by the AOA.
This isn't the only one
way to do it. The main key
thing to see here is that
I am listing the somatic
dysfunction findings,
and I'm trying to keep it
categorized by region.
and I'm also within this
document stating what I
treated that dysfunction with.
There is an option to list
just the structural exam
findings and then placing
the OMT that you utilized
under plan as per the NBOME
sample in the slide prior.
Once we've gone
through our history,
our physical exam,
we want to list our
assessments for
our patient, right?
Again, the assessments,
whether it be
hypertension, diabetes,
migraine, headache,
they all have a
specific code, right?
This ICD-10 code.
Most EMRs will have
something searchable that
if I start typing
hypertension, that code
will pop up. And then
some of those codes will
become a little bit
more detailed, whether
it's controlled,
uncontrolled, and so forth.
the office visit, you have
to make sure that the top
or first assessment for
your patient visit is your
medical diagnosis. What did
the patient come in for?
Patients don't come in
saying, oh, I have a somatic
dysfunction of my head.
Patients come in with headache,
with migraine, with
hypertension. So make sure that
when you're listing your
assessments, you prioritize
the reason for your patient
visit first. And then once
you have that down, you
could then list your somatic
dysfunction assessments,
right? So somatic dysfunctions
are separately listed as
ICD-10 codes, and they
correspond to the 10 body
regions, right? And so for
our migraine headache
patient, right? If they came
in and that's my main
diagnosis and main assessment,
that's going to be
listed first. So say
migraine and then here G43
.119. And if I want to then
list the somatic dysfunctions
after, right? M99
is the ICD-10 code for
somatic dysfunction for the
head. So then I would
list that under migraine.
So here's an example
of ICD-10 codes being
listed, right? So
again, somatic dysfunction
should never be the
only code or the first
code of the visit.
A somatic dysfunction
does not justify an
office visit. So here,
migraine is first,
can have neck pain with it.
It could be due to being
struck by a sea line.
Here's some very amusing ICD
-10 codes that you could
find within this booklet.
And then I list the different
dysfunctions that we had
listed in the osteopathic
structural exam, right? So
M99.00 is head, cervical,
thoracic, and rib, right?
So this is the breakdown
of the OMM ICD-10 codes,
again, it goes from head
down to abdomen and other
region, right? So if I'm
treating somebody and I treat
their diaphragm, or if I'm
doing mesenteric lift or
treating the ganglion, that
could fall under abdomen.
If I'm looking at the patient,
depending on what somatic
dysfunctions that I
diagnose, I could list the
corresponding somatic
dysfunction under assessment. it.
Some of the areas that we
treat are very straightforward,
right? So if I find
a somatic dysfunction
of the cranium of the face
that falls under head,
OA is the occipital atlas
atlanto joint. And so
OA is considered part of
the head. So if I make an
OA dysfunction inflammation
diagnosis that is
considered a cranial or,
yeah, cranial somatic
dysfunction in that region.
Cervical, straightforward,
thoracic, ribs, but
sometimes there's muscles
that may run from thoracic to
the cervical region. You
have muscles that run from
the upper extremity to the
lower back. So depending
on the muscle, depending
on where the region of
attachment is, right, it
might go across several areas.
So it's important to think
about where that muscle
is located. And some of
these joints or muscles may
span different regions.
And it's important for you
to select the region that
it best corresponds with.
So once we have our
history, our subjective
portion, objective
assessment, then we place
plan. If you feel that it's
easier to place the OMT
that you did within the
plan, that is also
something that you could
document, right? But it's
important to place within
your plan that you decided
to, you felt that it
was important to utilize
OMT and integrate that
treatment and procedure
on your patient that day.
So you have to document
somewhere within the
note that OMT was decided
to be performed as a
procedure on your patient.
And somewhere within
that note, you have to
define what were the somatic
dysfunctions that were
treated with the OMT.
So it's important
to document the
type of OMT that you
use. It's not enough
to say in your plan,
decide to use OMT.
And if you did
perform the OMT, then
you have to define
which techniques
you use for the
somatic dysfunctions.
With any procedure,
it's important to
include a procedure
note at the end.
Most of the time,
it's just a standard
patient was evaluated
and treated with OMT
as noted, and then their
treatment response.
Patient tolerated
the procedure well,
noted in a decreased pain,
increased range of motion,
or something after the
procedure. So ideally, you
want to note any sort
of functional gains post
-procedure. Increasing range
of motion is one, able to
move more fluidly from
sit to stand, able to
ambulate with less pain,
less asymmetry with
ambulation. So those are
just different examples
of what occurred after
the OMT procedure.
And this is something
you would do for any
procedure. So if you did
a skin biopsy, if you did
an injection, if there
was a surgical procedure,
it would be a little
bit more extensive, but
all documentation of a
procedure should have a
procedure note at the
end that states how the
patient responded and
tolerated the procedure.
So we have documentation
down. And again, it's
important to have proper
documentation because
ultimately, if you're
audited, that is the
evidence of what the
insurance company goes and
looks over. The lawyers
go and look over. Again,
only document what you
do, and it's important
that you definitely
document accurately, right?
So, how do we get paid for
this office visit procedure,
right? So, the office visit
itself is the evaluation
and management code,
right? The E&M code, right?
And the E&M code
is justified by our
documentation and
our assessments.
Any additional procedures,
OMT, injections, biopsies,
as long as they're a
separate service, is then
documented as a CPT code.
And those CPT codes are also
justified by assessments.
So we'll go into that.
So this is based on 2021
guidelines. guidelines we
could decide on our E&M
level or service right so
if I am seeing a patient
and they came in for
something that's not very
complex and it's something
that I could take care of
really quickly they came
in and they were just coming
in for a blood pressure
check and they had
hypertension and it's
diagnosis known essential
hypertension everything
controlled they're coming
in is for medication refill,
right? So the complexity
of this visit with just one
problem with everything
kind of status quo and they
just needed a check on their
blood pressure and their
weight and just kind of
seeing how they're doing, most
likely as an established
patient, this would be a
lower level, right? So if
you look at the chart here,
office visits could go from
level one to level five,
right? Level five
being the most complex,
level one being the
most straightforward.
A blood pressure check,
refill on medications,
everything's good, blood
pressure's good. It's
probably a level two
visit. Depending on whether
or not they're a new
visit or a established
patient, the new visit
codes is 9920 and then 2345.
Established is 9921 and
then one, two, three, four,
five. Do you remember the
numbers? No. I just want
to give you a framework
as to these E&M codes run
from one to five with
level five being the most
complex, level one being the
most straightforward. Most
of the times we don't even
build level one, right?
That's a lot of times
for level one is that
the doctor didn't even
see the patient that
came in for just a
nurse visit or check,
right?
Ultimately, what decides
whether you bill a level
one to level five is
the time and the medical
decision-making. So as
a physician, you are
compensated more if you
had to have a more complex
office visit. And what
changes the complexity of
that office is it often
is the number of problems
that the patient has
and that you addressed,
the amount and complexity
of the data you have to go
over, and then the risk of
complications, morbidity,
and mortality of that
patient in that presentation.
So it's a scale, right, of
how much you are going to
bill based on how complex
and how much time you
took to see that patient.
This is a daunting chart,
but I just wanted to give
you an idea of how it shifts
from a level two to a level
five. So if you look on
the left side of the column
here, you can see that again,
I'm going to build either
a new patient code, which
is on top, or established
patient code, which is on the
bottom. So the requirements
for a new patient versus
an established patient
is a little different on
time, as you can see there.
And then the level of medical
decision making, right?
So level two is
straightforward. Level three is
low. Level four becomes
moderate. Level five becomes
high. Once I reach a high
level of medical decision
making or a time greater
than 60 minutes for a
new patient, greater than 40
minutes for an established,
that bumps that office
visit to a level five,
right? So a patient with
atrial fibrillation on a
blood thinner that is,
the INR is too high. So
there's a high risk of
bleeding. They also have
hypertension that's uncontrolled,
right? So a diabetic
whose blood sugar is crazy
out of control and they
are getting new onset
numbness and tingling. So
when there's a new problem
that's uncontrolled or
exacerbated with other
medical history that you are
managing, a lot of times
that will then bump that
medical decision making
to a higher level, right?
The analysis of data, if
you're interpreting labs,
if you're ordering labs,
if you're looking over
referral, that also adds
to complexity. And then
the severity, right? Risk
of morbidity, mortality,
whether or not you have
to prescribe a medication,
whether or not you have to
refer, whether or not you
have to send them to an
emergency room or hospital,
all those things factor
into the complexity of care.
So again, a very daunting
chart, but I just want to
give you an overview of
as a physician, when you
interact with that patient,
ultimately that interaction
has to be documented
well within the chart and
based on the medical decision
making or the time spent
with the patient, that
will affect your level of
your coding for your
evaluation management of that
patient, right? Whether at
level one up to level five.
Talking specifically about OMT.
OMT is a procedure, right?
And so when we incorporate
OMT into our patients, right,
we are adding a procedure
to address their musculoskeletal
system to affect the
medical condition going on
in their body. That medical
condition or that assessment
is still your first
priority in listing when you
write your assessments down.
But as a procedure, we bill it
as a separate code or CPT code,
Right. So based on the number
of body regions that I treat.
Right. So there's
10 regions. We
went over that with
the assessments.
Based on the number
of body regions we
treat, we could bill
a specific code.
The code goes from
98925 up to 98929.
Right. The more
regions I treat, the
higher the level
of reimbursement.
So we have an evaluation and
management, let's say the
patient with migraine and
headaches, and let's say
it's a level three, it's, you
know, she's an established
patient, has migraines,
needs a refill, and has a
exacerbation of those headaches.
I decide as a physician
that OMT will be helpful
to treat some of the
musculoskeletal restrictions on
the neck and head and the upper
back and rib that contribute
to her migraine pain.
So I treated three to
four body regions. I
will bill an E&M for
a level three office
visit. And then I will
also bill for the OMT
that I diagnosed and
treated as a procedure.
Right. So it's important
that when we bill an office
visit or E&M and a procedure,
especially a separate
and distinct procedure,
something that's done.
that's apart from the
E&M, right? The OMT is
a separate procedure
that's not part of the
evaluation and management
of that patient. Patient
came in for migraine. I'm
doing everything as a physician
that I would normally do
for migraine. I am gathering
the history, diagnosing
that this is a migraine,
not a tension, not a cluster,
not a tumor. And then
through my examination, I
confirm that it is a migraine.
I decide to prescribe
medications. That's my
assessment. That's my plan.
In addition, I am doing a
separate billable service,
which is that OMT procedure,
right?
In that instance, in
order to get paid for
a visit and a procedure
on the same day,
in the billing world,
we have to add a
modifier. This is
called the 25 modifier.
So I'm adding a separate
CPT code onto the E&M.
So if I was to just
submit a bill and it's
an office visit and
a procedure code, but
I don't link the two
with a 25 modifier,
their insurance companies
won't pay me. So that's why
I'm trying to educate on
what this 25 modifier is.
It's a billing aspect where
we're now trying to get paid
for a procedure and an
office visit on the same day,
okay?
There are some
exceptions to the rule.
If you evaluated the
patient, right, so a lot of
times our family medicine
or other specialty services
are very, very packed. and
we would have 10 minute
visits or 15 minute visits
spaced between patients.
If you evaluate this
patient, let's say for
migraine, and then you say,
why don't you come back on
my another day on Friday
afternoon when I have a 20
minute visit span for you
to get OMT specifically.
So then you did your
evaluation and management and
then you had them come in
on a different day for the
OMT, then you will bill for
the OMT on that other day,
not on the same day. So in
that sense, you don't have
to use the 25 modifier
because you're not seeing the
person on the same exact
day that you are billing the
evaluation and management
or the same exact visit,
right? So the 25 modifier
is used only if you're doing
the office visit and the
procedure on the same day.
So putting this all
together, patient came
in for this office
visit, had a headache.
We did the SOAP note.
We did a full history
physical exam, diagnosed
the headache, and then
we integrated OMT because
we felt that that would
help the headache and
the medical condition.
The patient's an established
patient, moderate
complexity, so it's a level
three. So I'm going to bill
an office visit or
evaluation management 99213.
Those are my ICD-10
codes listed there.
Within my note, I do have
my somatic dysfunctions
listed out clearly in the
osteopathic structural exam in
the physical exam portion
or the objective portion.
And I'm going to bill the
OMT that I did too, which
was OMT for four regions.
I'm going to add that 25
modifier because I saw the
patient and I did the OMT
in the same visit. So
this is putting it all
together. This is what the
insurance company sees. They
see a super bill with the
E&M. these assessment codes
linked to that E&M and
then the procedure code
linking numbers two to five
with it with a 25 modifier
so that entire visit boils
down to that last line
so some key pointers
when we're reporting an
E&M and OMT on the same
day remember to add
that 25 modifier remember
that it's important
to have a comprehensive
documentation of
the patient's history,
including the OPQRST.
And the more details
you put in there, the
better it is to define
the complexity of care,
right?
Document the presence of
somatic dysfunction observed
during the examination. Give
a detailed account of the
specific regions of OMT,
including clarity of anatomical
regions addressed. Like
we said before, OMT is
billed based on body region.
So the better you document
the somatic dysfunctions
that you find in your patient
in your note, the easier
it will be for you to then
justify the treatment of these
regions, right? Make sure
you describe all the
techniques employed during the
OMT sessions and include
information on how the patient
responded the treatment
within that procedure note.
So understanding these
components of coding and billing
is crucial for accurate
reimbursement. If there's
inadequate documentation
or even incorrect billing,
it could have serious
consequences, including having
to pay back insurance
companies, even having to be
going to court, even jail,
even losing your license. So
So it's really important
that you understand the
importance of proper
documentation and incorrect or at
least understand the coding
and billing processes. And
you can say, oh, you know
what? I don't have to worry.
My company is going to do
that. Ultimately, as the
physician, you are responsible
for those actions of
your billing company. You
sign different agreements.
It's important to double
check what they're
billing for you. And
accurate billing will get you
reimbursed for what
you really deserve. You
could be underbilling,
which is also just as bad.
And so it's important to
really understand these
concepts. um the there's
constant guidelines in terms
of billing and coding um
and there's um frequent
changes so it's important
to be updated and understand
these different changes
ultimately we bear the
responsibility of adhering
to these standards um and in
terms of um omt it's important
to thoroughly document
the findings for omt um
the treatments that you do
um the coding for somatics
functions within the
assessments and then the
billing for OMT as a procedure
or any procedure to
have that understanding
of how to do that
correctly so you're
reimbursed for your
efforts and services.
Here are some
references that you go
over and I thank
you for your time.